dan we know that in 2012 you and Theo
screen works of the storm and Issa Rae
who's the awkward black girl we're both
prominent youtubers and we're wondering
are you seeing a shift that favors the
work that youtubers are doing their kind
of me you see now more than ever I think
there's there's a there's a definitely a
bigger popularity for these web series
now then that I think we've ever seen
before this point I mean just just case
in point the last few we doing with
these screenings you know eight months
out of the year um then it's been
growing over the years and we have a
nice Claudia's going in and the last two
screenings completely sold out huge
turnouts and mainly for these YouTube
web series that we've been screening
there's some of the projects we screen
are the ones that are directly
responsible for bringing a huge audience
getting the word out and all some people
responding say I'm coming to see this
stuff his I mean people that they know
directly you know a lot of time to
screenies people invite their friends
you know relatives or whatever whatever
crew members or whatnot these YouTube
these you two films and stuff that's
online when it's on machine Omar some
his other sites these these these big
followings they have and the fact that
people wanna go see them because it onto
the screen often they're online you see
them online all you want but to see a
new episode an older episode and with an
audience and be screen people have seen
the clamor for the stuff i mean there's
the turnouts were huge and it is
exciting to see these projects so i'm
trying to see that more and more now
when in terms of in terms of like
actually what we're showing when we
program them and the response and ticket
sales to those programs we have the
festival over here the the the the
webisode program that we have we always
program one or two programs every year
the festival of just you know online
content it sells out over here so you
see that now more than ever and when we
first start doing it we weren't so sure
we didn't even know if it was a good
category to do is it early on the
quality wasn't up to par would say that
could really well made short film with
some of the quality was a little bit
worse off you know there's not as much
money spent there's not as much time and
care spent but now that's changed the
qualities gotten better the attention
today
Hill's gotten better the quality of
equipments gotten better the money spent
because people see also the value of
where they can go they're self-made and
they can make money on this now it's not
just like I were doing this we're
getting attention people like us we have
facebook likes we have a fans people
watch the video and share it people are
actually you know this is the point when
I have hundreds of thousands of use to
millions of views for some of this stuff
that's actually there's dollars now
translating for that you know you have
some of these companies are acquiring
these film that evening part of the
films were really like hiring the
filmmakers to make a stuff on their
channels so getting paid to ger they're
hired guns essentially you're really
hired to make your content or it may
content like it on some of these sites
you know it goes from you too but it
sends out that some of these other
distribution companies and you know it's
a that online space has changed and it's
certainly important and it's certainly
I'm glad we do now moving now is it for
years but we started we weren't so sure
and now looking back like wow that was a
years ago now another court it's at now
from the start of this webisode thing
the screen a bit party and throw them up
on a screen outside to this is an
integral part of the vessel we have to
have a program from my content for
webisodes you have to happen I mean as a
short form content festival i say short
form content is there's there's other
areas those commercials and videos and
trailers but webisodes and online
content it fits right in there and it
has to be part of the vessel and now you
can't ignore it stuff it's no longer
just about short films and the student
filmmaking process we go to the film
school make a film it's all online stuff
the quality has gotten better and the
followings there and people are making
their own way and making their own money
where you can kind of bypassing some of
the general standard process the process
in place for all these years it's yeah
pretty exciting I mean because it's new
it's you don't know where is going to go
and and people can you can just you know
you can make it happen yourself you know
so that kind of mosca real spirit you
know it can it can take place here and
you can you can really thrive and that's
that's pretty cool and that's something
that up to the last few years wasn't
really the case was it wasn't the case
but it's definitely changed it was
definitely changed and you know you can
see you definitely see it with the
screenings the attendance and the the
kind of popularity of the stuff you've
shown
you